kyle hendricks take a peek at the
arsenal for today's starter slinker
change four seamer and curveball 13 wins
tied for the major league lead with
julio urias of the los angeles dodgers
kyle now sporting a 3.71
era seven innings of one run ball last
time out against the washington
nationals
on the ground to short romine handles
and throws him out adam engel will step
in hitting two
and a roller into center right on cue
i don't know what it is but he loves
hitting here at wrigley two men on one
away top of the first eloy jimenez
and that one hit on a bounce roman to
second for one onto first two and
hendricks able to get out of it six four
three they turn it nicely lancelin out
for his 20th start of the year looking
for his 11th win his era a touch over
two
a lot of strikeouts in 108 and
two-thirds he struck out 122. a 3-2 home
he got him looking ortegan will not
argue well sometimes you get out guess
and i'm not sure exactly what he's
looking for but he gets a heater right
down the middle here's schwendell former
royal and athletic
and he struck him out and that'll do it
two k's in the first nothing nothing
from wrigley greg dykman making his
major league debut
on a hop it's hernandez in short right
to make the play
robinson chirinos the catcher for the
cubs
with two out in the inning
i fly to right vaughn
in the corner
makes a catch
after two from wrigley field nothing
nothing
sarah fernandez will be first up against
kyle hendricks
and that one in there got him looking
hernandez didn't like the call from
brian o'nora it sticks around
to let him know that's three straight
strikeouts so here's andersondow tim old
for one grounded out his first time
right in on his hands short hopper
knocked down romi throw to first out at
first
and they go one two three again sergio
alcantara playing second base for the
cubs 24 year old infielder
line right to tim for the out
hendricks a career oh 99 batter and that
one right off the back side of lynn
anderson will throw to first and get him
one to six to three he gets an assist
out of that yeah i think lance is going
to be in pretty good shape after that
hit him in probably the best spot you
could hit him and they've got something
cooking for alloy two on nobody else
bring him up
and he does
and a big out andrew vaughn will hit
with runners at first and third one away
no score and a liner into center will
give the white sox the lead here comes
engel
it's one to nothing
andrew vaughn staying hot sebby zavala
will look to bring in a few more two out
in the inning first and second for the
sox
base it to right
abrayu around third
here's the throw by dykman it's two
nothing
and that was a big hit certainly
punching it through the right side rbi
number nine better than that it's a two
to nothing score in this game and that
loads the bags for lance lynn
and they got him to swing and miss there
and that is that white sox take the lead
it's 2-0 midway in the fourth half
doubled with two outs in the first was
stranded
and strikes him out on a foul tip number
three for lynn here's schwendell
swinging a miss back-to-back case well
the guys like lance lynn he knows how to
do that greg dykman in his major league
debut grounded out his first time
one in the air out towards right field
and it finds space first major league
hit for greg dykman and the dugout
waving for the baseball andrew romine
they hit her 2-2
on the ground to tim down to a knee
and lynn with that shut down fourth and
the cubs will have the bottom three in
their order here in the fifth
swing and a miss strike three it's the
fifth strikeout for lancelin today so
two walks here in the inning two away
and it'll bring up matt duffy
crawl strike three
so lynn
gets out of it the cup strand two
for two against the team that brought
him into the professional ranks of major
league baseball
driven to right
in the corner
and it's going to get to the wall as
eloy will make his way to second he's
got a double
his base hit last night was to right
field this time he hit it a bundle to
right field one down the right head of
batting sebby zavala to step in payoff
pitch
and that one punch coming home
and they get the tag on goodwin of the
out of the play alcantara with a strike
and on contact with goodwin coming home
they get the second out lancelin will
step in he'll take this a b bases loaded
two away
and hendrix
carves up lynn and the white sox leave
them loaded another good outing today
for kyle hendricks
it's two nothing white sox were midway
in the sixth french windell the first
baseman for the cubs is over two with
two strikeouts
he struck him out for the third time
first pitch now to greg dykeman it's a
fly ball into left anderson going back
vaughn coming on he'll make the catch
go down to his knees and just miss a
collision with tim anderson that was
scary
mango will come up one out in the inning
that is a fair ball in the left field
corner
three-hit day for adam engel maybe he
can steal third again
brian goodwin to bet for the first time
today
swaying and a miss and jewel able to get
goodwin
and he pitches himself out of the jam
we will get a pitching change
lance lynn was brilliant once again and
he'll get a nice ovation from the sox
fans in the ballpark so here's bode now
with runners at the corners
lined into left field vaughn makes the
catch
tagging from third is romine bodie with
a line drive sacrifice fly and it's a
2-1 game patrick wisdom got plenty of
power so here's the situation two away
runner on first two to one sucks
the payoff pitch
in the air to right this will get him
out of it
i believe goodwin backpedaling he's got
it and after seven it's 2-1 white sox
new pitcher is on to face cesar
hernandez left-handed relayer kyle ryan
lefty home fly ball well hit
gone
what'd you say about power
that's his side for me
that's not a real good pitching change
for david ross because you turn the guys
at 18 home runs many more home runs
right handed then left you turn him
around to hit right-handed and he adds a
couple more it's a four to one game
bottom of the eight craig kimbrell back
at wrigley field and pitching against
the cubs this time
lined out of the left center field and
that's a base hit duffy will stop at
second schwindel with a knock
two ounce two on andrew romine at the
plate
swing and a ball drilled in the air
right field that one going back and it's
gone home run for romine and we are tied
wow what a moment maybe andrew vaughn
was right when he was playing role mine
so deep in right field earlier in this
ball game the cubs and the winning run
on first with two out ian happ the
three-hitter now swing and a miss
four strikeouts for hendricks we go to
the 10th inning sox four
cubs four jose abreu is the runner at
second base goodwin came on in relief of
eloy jimenez that was back in the top of
the sixth
driven to left it's deep it is gone
brian goodwin
with a two-run homer
that was a line drive rocket a no
doubter gavin sheets is inserted as the
pinch batter in the pitcher spot
ground ball base hit here comes fawn
it's a three-run lead
gavin sheets comes through tim anderson
will bat go for five today three ground
outs two strikeouts
tim with a base hit there's the salvage
it's eight to four and the cubs need
base runners they trail by four the
bottom of the tenth inning frank
schwendell leads it off
in the air towering fly ball left field
and that one is gonna go
a two-run homer for frank schwendel
and just like that the cubs get two back
it's eight six
so here's davies
and he drives one out in the left center
angle on the move he's got it and the
white sox win this wild one in 10
innings
8-6 the final